now racial activists love to opine don't
they about the legacy of George Floyd
and sure while there may be more
attention now paid to training police
officers and weeding out problem
recruits there's also a dangerous
Boomerang effect that's terrorizing
American cities and businesses more
crime the mob of at least a thousand
kids and teenagers that swarmed New York
City's Union Square on Friday is a case
in point now a PlayStation giveaway that
was you know people gathered for this
quickly turned into a violent
free-for-all where police were attacked
with bottles rocks and fireworks
[Applause]
[Music]
you will be arrested for unlawful
assembly
now since the summer of 2020 it's
basically been a Non-Stop blur of
violent crime committed by unrepentant
thugs from people who knock over
convenience stores and department stores
with Brazen arrogance to beating
defenseless women and seniors and
sometimes even in broad daylight
the perpetrators almost seem to act as
if they're Justified don't they after
all in our everyone's a victim culture
you can write past wrongs by chucking a
full water bottle now at law enforcement
because even if they're not obviously
racist police officers they're part of a
racist organization
now that's the flavor of the post-floid
propaganda that we've seen saturate
social media and even at times make its
way into school curricula and even in
the cities plagued by crime liberal
Mayors are still unafraid to say it like
it is
police is not going to be able to
resolve these issues on our own the
great level of restraint
we saw Yesterday by the New York City
Police Department that could have turned
really ugly these are young people we
have to you know be mindful of that as
we bring back order Mary mayor Adams
this Riot didn't turn
ugly it was ugly and it was ugly because
there are rarely repercussions for the
oppressed and the Misunderstood
in fact for most well Crime Pays
now young people are angry because
they're being taught that their anger is
righteous it's Justified and that
oftentimes non-minorities just hate them
remember this scene from a Florida
school last fall where one student felt
entitled to tackle a police officer who
was working on school grounds or what
happened earlier this year when a
teacher had the nerve to take away a
student's Nintendo switch
but of course celebrities and Elites you
know they're usually unfazed by this
Behavior because it rarely affects them
so they're shocked when members of their
beloved audience end up hurling objects
at them while they're on stage
[Music]
now these Mega Stars some of whom
indulge black lives matter and vilified
police themselves help create this
madness ditto with left-wing politicians
and woke corporate CEOs who were too
busy virtue signaling on Race to think
about where all this is going to lead
ain't nothing to do man until police
come in
to a world where criminals fear no
consequences and were those who stand up
to them are most likely to be prosecuted
that's why last week a deranged felon in
California felt totally comfortable
targeting a 7-Eleven store
one he's suspected by the way of robbing
twice before in the same 24-hour period
when two of the workers stepped in to
defend themselves in the store most of
America cheered the video went viral but
in our upside down post-floyd world
the store clerks are being investigated
so the left may not have defunded the
police but they helped set a dynamic
where suddenly the victims are treated
like aggressors and the aggressors as
victims
so the message to law-abiding citizens
if you're robbed or you're threatened
stand by placidly
don't put up a fight ever
After All America has a lot to atone for
so just consider it Payback
joining us now is Xavier de Rosso
ex-black lives matter activist and
prageru personality uh Xavier this
victimhood mentality that were
encouraging and nurturing where does
this all end up and we're seeing some of
it play out on our streets but what else
is coming
you know cities like New York City and
Chicago have gone completely Rogue
because there's just such a lack of
accountability there are no consequences
and what we're seeing instead now is
there's an entire generation of people
who are so used to not being condemned
for this bad behavior that they don't
even know the skill set of taking
accountability what they learn instead
from fraudulent organizations like black
lives matter is that you should shift
the blame to a relevant outdated issues
like systemic racism rather looking
yourself in the mirror and recognizing
that you need to change there's a reason
that most of the people displaying these
violent behaviors are not first-time
offenders if there was nothing to stop
them from committing this crime in the
first place then what's going to stop
them the fifth sixth and seventh time
well I mean when mayor Adams says it
could have gotten ugly we were watching
the video thinking what are you talking
about and by the way Xavier um Chicago
as we've mentioned is experiencing these
teen takeovers as well and I mean that's
a nice way of putting it but here's what
Mayor Johnson had to say watch this
oh you're not aware of some of these
large Gatherings
no that's that's that's that's that's
not appropriate we're not talking about
mob actions I didn't say that but we
have to be very careful when we use
language to describe certain Behavior I
mean to refer to children as like Baby
Al Capone's it's not appropriate
not appropriate Xavier
it's not appropriate it's funny they say
that this is getting ugly but to me it
looks hideous in fact it's honestly
embarrassing for Humanity to see where
we've gone as a society and what I need
parents especially when you see these
young people being destructive they need
to realize it's not law enforcement's
job to babysit their kids but if they
continue to just sit back and allow
their kids and their Community to be so
destructive then eventually the judicial
system is going to jump in and I don't
want to hear anybody complaining that
they're oppressed because they decided
to become a convict at 18 years old
Xavier thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else